érable c'est quelque chose qui est
horrible de se faire arracher la peau
les chiens qui ont du sens dans les
dents paix qui est qui qui qui tâta qui
reviennent pc et moi ce que je pense
c'est au qu'il faut que ce que je veux
que ce que je fais comment je vais les
arrêter mais bon tu arrêter ils vont
tuer arrêter un moment donné mais non
ils continuent et continuent gt gt une
proie
c'est pouvait pourquoi ça pouvait
exister des chiens comme ça qu'est ce
qui vous a sauvé moi je pensais vraiment
je me suis vraiment battu battu battu je
me raconte ses chiens et chats une
personne forte j'ai physiquement assez
forte
g je me suis pas évanoui puis je sais
c'est le goût de vivre
je voulais pas mourir je t'aime vraiment
décidé je mets un moment donné musique
bat ça y est dense et je vais mourir
c'est plus possible puis capable il me
lâche pas et là j'ai entendu le coup de
sifflet et un premier chien s'est levé
la tête et il est parti il est retourné
à la maison
le deuxième arrêté a suivi un trou le
troisième s'est acharné encore sur moi
est parti et là j'ai demandé je sors moi
j'ai essayé de marcher puis je me suis
dit t'es pas cap' âge je me suis aperçu
que tout ça était ouvert ma jambe était
mon manger les extrémités mon déchiré
et j'aime ont enlevé les muscles achi
vous étiez de la viande
je t'ai de l'avion gt r
comme le chevreuil là à
que des animaux à tacle et alors là j'ai
appelé de l'ied juste écrit j'ai crié et
puis là le propriétaire de le
propriétaire des chiens et est arrivé à
la barre puis asie oh my god jeudi à
canet wan wan wide l'accord puis le y
est allé il est retourné à sa maison
puis ça m'a paru une éternité
vous êtes évanouie non je me suis jamais
venu et jamais et j'ai ils m'ont mis
dans la dans l'ambulance et mélissa
d'une des premiers répondants qui est
elle est venue avec moi dans l'ambulance
est elle à alma parler elle a continué à
voulait que je reste éveillé lâche ma
peau lâche moi pour la killer m'a donné
pour enfin arriver à sherbrooke
puis je me suis laissé aller vous senti
que vous étiez un steak avec le terrain
je ne sais pas j'étais arrivé là à
l'urgence pilotes ouais
et là c'est tout le combat qui
s'amorçait oui puis je me suis réveillé
renault -2 nouveau cap
l'opération apparemment duré 8 heures
ils ont travaillé les eaux mon conjoint
m'a raconté que au bout de huit heures
ils sont sortis avait des sueurs killer
couler tellement il avait travaillé pour
essayer de réparer toutes les toutes les
vaisseaux et les nerfs l'essai de
recoudre le mieux qu'ils pouvaient il
faut que la loi impose que c'est ces
propriétaires devraient prendre
premièrement des cours des cours
d'obéissance et devrait être être
responsable de prendre des assurances
des assurances et je dis ça parce que
j'ai eu des soins
incroyable je peux même pas m'imaginer
le coût que cela représente 1
ces soins que j'ai reçus à notre société
s'il devait ne pas y avoir d'accusations
de portées contre alan brown
comment réagiriez-vous au jeu je
comprends je suis alors dans une dans la
mauvaise société je suis pas dans la
bonne société
je suis dans une société où l'animal est
plus important que la personne